forscherinnen und forscher befürchten
eine alien-invasion wenn david baker
sein metier projekt durch zb die steht
dabei für messaging extraterrestrial
intelligence also so viel wie
nachrichten an außerirdische
intelligenzen der mann will in großem
stil nachrichten ins all senden um
endlich mit aliens in kontakt zu treten
doch viele warnen vor solch einem
eigenmächtigen schritt jetzt wirklich
vom feinsten fixen herzlich willkommen
ja wir hatten das thema schon mal hier
doch jetzt wird es konkret angegangen
beim letzten mal ging es um die signale
die wir mit atombombentest und dem
funkverkehr zwischen boten ins weltall
aus gesendet haben und damit vielleicht
feindlich gesinnte außerirdische zu uns
gelockt haben die mobbing warm vor der
kontaktaufnahme mit denen er vergleicht
die mehr kontakt mit der entdeckung
amerikas die urbevölkerung wurden dort
fast vernichtet und die europäer nahmen
den gesamten kontinent ein laut hawking
würde genau das auch mit einer spezies
passieren wie uns einige milliarden
jahre voraus sein könnte wenn wir uns
unter umständen nicht freundlich gesinnt
wären dann wären wir ein leichtes viel
und sie müssen uns dabei nicht mal
feindlich gesinnt sein
das medi projekt wird jetzt ganz konkret
mit einer erklärung angegangen die unter
anderem auch von ihnen musk
unterzeichnet worden ist
in der erklärung wird gewarnt dass
nahezu uns lebende aliens unsere
radiosignale den weltraummüll und so
weiter und so fort aufgespürt haben
könnten aber dass immer noch schwieriger
ist als ein gezieltes signal abpfiff und
wie hoch waren sie vor außerirdischen
wir wissen nichts über die intentionen
und fähigkeiten und es ist unmöglich
vorherzusagen ob sie gut artig oder
feindlich gestimmt sind aber warum gibt
es jetzt so einen aufruhr um medicopter
gab es ja schon versuche kontakt zu
ihnen aufzunehmen verteilen 70 schickte
die nasa die pioneer 10 und 19 73 die
pioneer 11 mit einer botschaft in den
weltraum 1977 dann beute 1 und 2 und
mozart 74 wurde vom arecibo
radioteleskop die arecibo botschaft
ausgesendet die idee hatte der
astrophysiker frank drake der auch die
drake formel entwickelt hat mit ihr kann
man ausrechnen wieviele außerirdische
zivilisationen sich in aller
galaxie befinden allerdings wenn die
faktoren in der formel von so vielen
umständen und schätzungen abhängig dass
die ergebnisse höchst unterschiedlich
sind für unsere galaxie schwank das
ergebnis zwischen zwei und vier
millionen zivilisation ist er ist auf
jeden fall von der existenz von aliens
überzeugt und dachte sich deshalb diese
nachricht aus wie wurde in den
kugelsternhaufen im breitling gewendet
in rund 25.000 jahren wird die botschaft
dort ankommen so dass wir in 50.000
jahren mit einer nachricht rechnen
können wenn es uns dann noch gibt alles
nur pille fit sagt astrophysiker und
mitgründer jay koch er will das projekt
in großem stil angehen wenn wir
außerirdische wirklich mit einem signal
erreichen wollen dann müssen wir es
richtig machen er will am 2018 ein
signal zu proxima centauri bebt oder
zugleich 111 schicken
wieso ein paar lichtjahre entfernt und
sie könnten neben der wagen beide
umkreisen ihren heimatstern in der
habitablen zone also in der bewohnbaren
zone wo ich leben geben kann und es
könnte deshalb eben also auch
tatsächlich intelligentes leben dort
leben und wenn koch will noch etwas
anderes machen nicht nur die gezielte
auswahl der empfänger gehört zu seiner
idee sondern auch die dauer
sie soll nämlich erstmal nicht enden
eine dauerhafte sendung der signal für
den beiden planeten und auch die
nachricht selbst soll durchdachter als
die bisherigen seien keine bilder keine
töne sondern mathematik weil koch geht
davon aus dass auch dort wie beim wg
projekt hier auf der erde
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nach signalen suchen eine sprache würden
sie also in jedem fall verstehen die der
mathematik beginnen würde die botschaft
mit zwei signalen wird eine dauer zwei
sekunden und das nächste drei sekunden
dann folgt ein fünfstündiges signal
addition ich bin sehr gespannt wie
dieses projekt in die tat umgesetzt wird
viel finden dass ein solches projekt
eine erlaubnis der menschheit der uno
benötigt aber bitte bisher gibt es keine
entsprechenden regelung was man ihr
schreibt es in die kommentare ich halte
euch natürlich hier zum thema auf dem
laufenden wenn er kein video dazu
verpassen
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
unvergesslich den
auf die glocke ja hier geht es weiter
mit müssen wir einen alien angriff
fürchten mit noch mehr infos zum thema
wenn es euch interessiert dann umwegen
draufklicken und ansonsten das land
bleibt preis